six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number we are taking
calls for the first time in 2017 we'll
go to the caller from the six six one
area code caller what's your name and
where are you calling from hi my name is
Joseph and I'm from California
alright what's on your mind um yes would
all this talk about repealing the
Affordable Care Act I was wondering why
can't we just give everyone in United
States the same kind of medical care
politicians have well right so there's a
few different reasons I mean number one
the so-called Cadillac insurance plans
that were supposed to be
disincentivizing through business tax
law are by and large the ones that
elected officials in Washington get so
those are very very expensive plans
number two I mean I think the route of
your question is
can't we just figure out a way to make
sure everybody's covered and that it
doesn't break the bank for them to get a
basic level of health care and the
answer is we absolutely can do it we
just do not have the political will to
do it and this is a combination of the
idea the amorphous idea that the free
market capitalist way which is not even
really what it is but the supposed at
free market capitalist way is the best
way combined with what I call strict
father morality on the right which is
the idea that even if you make a
fiscally conservative argument too many
ideological Republicans as to why it
would be cheaper to just ensure
everybody have taxes go up slightly but
you no longer have businesses and
employees combining to pay for health
insurance even if you make the fiscal
argument many of them fundamentally
believe that unless you were buying your
health insurance you don't deserve
health insurance you deserve to be
punished in a way and this relates to
their view on birth control and so many
other areas so we when you say why can't
we we absolutely can but not under the
current political and cultural system
that we have in our country does that
make sense yes yeah it's sad that's very
very sad unfortunately yeah
all right well thank you so much for the
call really really appreciate it good
question yeah a lot of these problems do
have solutions we pretend like they
don't but they really do have solutions
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the David Pakman
show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated